so i think we're speaking
uh in sort of uh idealistic terms about
the power of capitals and what it works
well
is there any aspects that you think that
don't work
well in a free market in all the basic
pragmatic truths that
we're talking about is there is there
ways it can go wrong
so i would first argue that we
have never seen an actual
purely free market um
closest example would be
you know kind of geopolitically we have
a free market and that governments are
not necessarily governed
but they are premised on
governing large groups of individuals so
that's not doesn't exactly
you mean between governments yes
see but isn't there still so a free
market maybe you can correct me
is the free market still grounded in the
ideas of
you know property rights and all those
kinds of things right so governments
tend to also sometimes be violent
towards each other that's right so they
don't respect
all the basic aspects of capitalism
that's right so
maybe another way to look at this is
that gold
is the original governor of government
actually and this is the reason
governments have
abused and gone off of the gold standard
so historically if you are a
bank or a nation state and
you produce more currency
than your gold reserves can justify
then people then gold will flow out of
your bank or out of your country
so there's this natural check um
via the money that be via
capitalistic money which is gold right
gold was selected by the free market
it's not decreed by a government
it it provided this natural check on
government action
so my i guess to get back to the
original question is
we've never seen a pure free market
because money has always been
monopolized
and coerced frankly so
to try and answer what goes wrong with a
free market is really difficult because
we've never
actually seen it and i would define free
market is
one in which government only protects
life liberty and property and so that's
very minimal role
in society again just as network
security for for the economic trade
network
and anything that any government
function that goes beyond
those three core functions which by the
way are pretty much the core tenets of
morality as well
so government's just really intended to
preserve uh you know natural law if you
will
anything that goes beyond that is
moves us closer to an unfree market so
every
regulation every act of coercion um is
actually
a a gradation closer to
a purely unfree market which would be a
monopoly so
in terms of what i guess theoretically
we could say goes wrong in the free
market
is that it's volatile it's it's trading
off
it's accepting short-term short-term
volatility
uh in exchange for less long-run
volatility yeah
and this tends to be the way of nature
by the way so if we
we look at something like there's a
region
in north america called baja california
and it runs
into the united states and it runs down
into mexico as well
so the same topology but two different
jurisdictions
in the u.s uh we very heavily manage
forest fires we're trying to manage
nature effectively
whereas in mexico it's much more
unregulated it just when wildfires
spring up
they let them burn off north america
when wildfires spring up we're actually
extinguishing them so we're constantly
trying to dampen the short-run
volatility of these small
brush fires whereas in mexico we just
let them burn we let nature do its thing
yeah the consequence of this is that
the wildfires still occur eventually but
they're much larger and much more
devastating in north america where human
intervention has occurred
because it is um it's
dampening nature's natural corrective
mechanism of clearing this underbrush
with these
more frequent and smaller fires at the
cost of much larger
fires so again we're delaying short-term
volatility and exacerbating long-run
volatility
and in mexico it's the opposite right
just these wildfires burn
much smaller more continuously over time
the further effect of that in north
america is that the fires can get so big
and so hot that it burns away the top
soil
so it actually destroys the fertility of
the soil itself
so the point of this is that human
intervention
right even the intention behind uh north
american authorities managing that
forest fire is to
create less destruction that is the
intention
but the intention is divergent from the
outcome
so and telephone speak you would say
that human intervention
moves us from mediastan
into extremistan so mediocristan
would be something much more like nature
where for instance you can't double your
body weight
in a day probably can't even do it in a
year right
but in extremis stand which is something
much more information based
you can double or
send your net worth to zero in a single
trade in a single moment
right so when we try and intervene with
natural biological systems that have
these feedback loops we actually start
to push the system more
to behave more like an extremist and
system
that has you know less short-run
volatility but but
more extreme long-run volatility so but
the question is
where you look at uh capitalism or
communism for example
and by the way yes i will talk to
somebody who's a marxist or communist
like richard wolff is
a pretty eloquent defender of these
ideas because it's
it's always good to really understand
ideas as opposed to just reject them
off hand when you look at
the system of capitalism or the system
of communism
there's ideals and a lot of people argue
in this perfect
form would actually be good for the
world the question is
how resilient are they to the corruption
of human nature and i mean
you're saying that there's not a there's
never been a free market
it's a very true statement the question
is
how resilient is capitalism or whatever
implementations of capitalism we had up
to this point
to human nature where one person would
become successful
at through legitimate means
then starts to try to manipulate the
system that takes it away from a free
market
or takes it away from uh the the things
that
gave him the riches in the first place
and then uh
try to through corruption get more get
this the thing you said
uh the lazy human ways now i try to
figure out how to get something for
nothing that's right
so how resilient do you think is
capitalism to that
well the best implementation we've had
of it
really has been the united states
i think up until this point but it's
still the central banking itself this
was
in the 1848 manifesto of the communist
party measure number five
reads a an exclusive state monopoly
and centralized control over cash and
credit so the central bank
is a marxist or communist institution
it is antithetical to the free market
principles on which the united states
was founded
and indeed the united states resisted
the implementation of a central bank
i think it was andrew jackson i know
there was the first
national bank the second national bank
were both disbanded
and then uh andrew jackson which is my
favorite tennessean he's
he has some famous quotes about routing
out the bankers like a den of vipers
i think he punched one of the central
bankers in the face uh
back when our leaders were were a bit a
bit more badass i guess you might say
and you know finally in 1913
the the federal reserve was was
implemented
and um it's been kind of all downhill
from there
so what is uh can you oh second um i was
just going to say that
the communism and capitalism it's also a
matter of scale
you know the ideal behind communism is
uh from each according to their ability
to each according to their need
sounds beautiful right sounds like a
great peaceful harmonious way to
organize ourselves
the problem is and and by the way i am a
communist
in my family in my home right right very
small
scales yes in your very small circles of
trust you're much more
likely to behave selflessly towards one
another by the way i look forward to the
bitcoin community clipping out that part
saying that rapper breedlove is a
communist and the ideals of communism
are beautiful
yeah context matters people
go ahead um but to your point it does
not
scale right as we
move into this larger system of
socioeconomic cooperation
which is necessary to deepen the
division of labor
to generate more wealth right we need to
interact with one another on much larger
scales
than this communistic utopian ideal
we get into the realm of capitalism
where we need really sound rules
hard rules consensus verifiability
um and frankly prices because the other
thing in com
in soviet russia is they tried to
replace the profit motive or the price
signal
with this devotion to this nationalistic
faith and devotion
where it's like you don't need
self-interest anymore you don't need
prices or profits you can just protect
mother russia
right and serve mother russia and that
would create wealth
and what happened right they destroyed
price signals
there were shortages there were famines
there's um
all levels of corruption because you
know to your point it's
once you people have to run the system
no matter what
so when you're when people are always
pursuing something for nothing and you
put someone in a seat of
much closer to absolute power where
they're making all the pricing decisions
they own all the productive factors in
the economy
they're not beholden to any market force
there's no
market check on their action
that that institution tends to become
more corrupt
and further it's it's an inferior
resource strategy
i alluded to this earlier where the
other way to think about
free market versus central planning
is it's decentralized or distributed
computing
versus centralized computing so each one
of us
i think the the number is 120 bits per
second of active awareness
so we can take in clearly we process a
lot more than that but our active
awareness i think is 120 bits per second
in a centralized planning body like in
soviet russia
they had the pricings are maybe they had
10 20 000 people deciding the prices for
the entire country
you're only getting that much data
throughput right 20
000 people times 120 bits per second
whereas in a free market
if everyone is free to interact with
deep capital markets based on an
accurate price
you're getting the data throughput of
120 bits per second
times the entire economy right so you're
getting
it's a more efficient means for
disseminating knowledge effectively and
then again knowledge
is just the more knowledge uh a
socioeconomic structure can contain the
more wealthy it is
right prices tools all these things are
just knowledge so
in that respect that's why something
like capitalism
even in its marginalized form state
capitalism out competes
communism it's a it's distributed
computing versus centralized computing
you